elle a débuté l'escalade à 11 ans depuis
elle ne cesse de grimper jusqu'au plus
haut niveau 3 fois championne du monde
en catégorie Jeune 4 fois championne de
France seniors Caroline cavaldini a 25
ans est actuellement 5e du classement
mondial rien que ça rencontre à flan de
falaise accrochez-vous
j'ai été lancée dans des voies comme ça
qui était beaucoup trop dur pour moi à
la base j'ai travaillé pendant des
années donc sur rocher je le connais à
la fois je le connais par cœur et je
l'ai presque un peu oublié
mais donc c'est ma c'est ma falaise
d'enfance c'est c'est mon espèce de
terrain terrain de jeu particulier avec
mes amis j'ai trois milliards de
souvenirs ici la petite surdouée de
l'escalade de difficulté nous a donné
rendez-vous sur le blog qu'il a vu
grandir à bassin plat dans la ravine
entre Saint-Pierre et Terre Sainte et
donc il y avait vraiment des voix très
très intéressantes c'est très technique
le rocher très compact dans tout ce
qu'on va avoir c'est des angles en prise
de main et le pied est en adhérence sur
le rocher à plat parce qu'il y a pas de
prise donc c'est à la fois physique et
très technique parce qu'il faut placer
son pied placer le poids du corps
correctement donc c'est une falaise qui
est vraiment très intéressante d'un
point de vue technique et qui présente
des voix très intéressantes et très dur
et je pense que c'est la plus belle
falaise de l'île de la Réunion
je vais de l'escalade de difficulté en
fait il existe trois possibilités trois
sous disciplines en escalade est-ce
qu'elle a de vitesse logique le but du
jeu c'est le plus vite possible escalade
de difficultés ce que je pratique avec
des corps des baudrier sur des parois
assez hautes et escalade de blocs sans
cordes sur des sur des blocs de 4 mètres
maximum pourquoi je fais de la
difficulté parce que pour moi c'est la
discipline reine
l'enjeu c'est d'arriver en haut de la
voix la voix la plus difficile possible
donc ce que j'aime dans l'escalade c'est
à quel point on se perd quand on grimpe
dans les mouvements quel point on
s'oublie à quel point on n'existe plus
et tout ce qui existe c'est le mouvement
suivant et comment le faire
j'en ai besoin
l'oublia un papy
là je suis à la Réunion il y a quelques
semaines j'étais en Turquie un mois
avant j'étais au Maroc
qui me fait découvrir des gens géniaux
les grimpeurs sont géniaux des gens très
intéressants
j'adore le processus de découvrir une
falaise et c'est les voix donner à fond
et y arriver ou pas y arriver mais
essayez vous souhaite une très bonne
découverte de la grimpe et je vous dis
au revoir